are you single alone and in need of
something sweet in your life I have a
girlfriend oh just go along with it I'm
going to show you how to make an amazing
quickie microwave dessert for one let's
do it all right one dice Apple gonna add
about a half a tablespoon or so of brown
sugar
plus a teaspoon of butter then I added
some cinnamon spice I'm gonna pop this
into the microwave for four minutes
until it's softened and deliciously
golden to top it off we got some full
fat Greek yogurt some toasted pecans and
a couple apple chips
all right let's recap we got lots of
fiber in our apples plus our apple chips
healthy fats and the pecans and lots of
protein in our Greek yogurt and it
literally took a few minutes to make
nature's candy